[Música]
Hola bienvenidos al debate de France 24
comenzó el 2023 y comenzó con tremendo
sacudón con los hechos recientes en
Brasil y en Perú que la espera entonces
a la región de América Latina para este
año nuevo un año que según los analistas
tendrá también complejidades a nivel
económico y donde se tendrán que asentar
las bases de esos virajes políticos que
hubo a lo largo del 2022 veamos Entonces
cuál es la agenda de los temas que vamos
a tratar a lo largo de este programa
para el 2023 qué perspectivas tendremos
Entonces en cuanto a la estabilidad
política no solamente vamos a estar
hablando del caso de Brasil y de Perú
Tenemos que hablar también de esos
países en donde los gobiernos tendrán
que asentarse como en el caso de chile y
como en el caso de Colombia hablaremos
también de la economía la mayoría de los
países están haciendo frente a una alta
inflación también hay un rezago
tecnológico y hay cierto malestar social
y por supuesto la migración que es un
tema transversal para la región de
América Latina saben ustedes las
complejidades que hay la situación que
hay en la frontera común entre Colombia
y Panamá y también el desarrollo de
estas caravanas que tienen lugar en
Centroamérica rumbo a México y Estados
Unidos será otro año en el que vamos a
tener que hablar de falta de integración
Tal parece que sí ya hemos visto ese
mercosur como está de dividido y la
alianza del Pacífico qué tal parece que
no termina de despegar y también
Tendremos que hablar entonces de
gobiernos que marcan distancias de otros
simplemente Por no tener afinidades
políticas Qué pasará con los países que
tienen gobiernos ya desgastados estamos
hablando de Cuba de Nicaragua de
Venezuela que repercusión tendrá la
prolongación de la guerra en Ucrania en
nuestra región porque ya vimos a lo
largo del 2022 que sí tuvo impacto ese
conflicto en el este de Europa para la
región de América Latina pues hoy en el
debate de France 24 entonces delineamos
las perspectivas de lo que puede ser el
2023 para América Latina y que lo espera
entonces a los países de la región para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a Iván
briscoe Él es director del programa para
América Latina y el Caribe de crisis
Group y también está con nosotros Diego
Sánchez anncoecha de los profesor de
economía política y director del
departamento de desarrollo Internacional
de la Universidad de Oxford en el Reino
Unido a nuestros televidentes también
les recuerdo que ustedes también son
parte de esta de esta mesa de debate
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook y en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba el
debate_f24 arroba santilogo les recuerdo
la etiqueta es numeral el debate f-24 y
no olviden también que todos los
contenidos de este programa también
están disponibles en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
Bueno pues comenzamos entonces Este
primer programa del 2023 dándoles la
bienvenida a Iván Iván Gracias por estar
con nosotros aquí en el programa en
France 24 y comienzo para que hagamos un
panorama general de algunos temas
puntuales que usted quiera destacar de
este balance que usted hace la
perspectiva para el 2023 y luego vamos
profundizando en esos temas que estaba
yo mencionando en la introducción del
programa adelante bienvenido Muchas
gracias Un placer estar con ustedes
Obviamente el principio del año ha sido
de una serie de noticias que que digamos
son malos augurios para el año que viene
lo que hemos visto en Brasil el domingo
con el motín de los fundamentalistas de
partidarios de bolsonaro obviamente la
violencia que acabamos de ver en el sur
de Perú también
y este muestran obviamente son
diferentes facetas de la inestabilidad
política no en Perú vemos un nivel
altísima de polarización con un
deterioro de la institucionalidad del
estado que hace que la gente ha perdido
su su confianza en el estado peruano a
la vez que los diferentes fuerzas
políticas no encuentran forma de digamos
de interesar el rumbo y digamos
consolidar de nuevo un cierto
legitimidad en el estado y eso y es un
caso extremadamente preocupante porque
no sabemos cuándo va a terminar la
violencia lo interesante en Brasil era
que este fue una historia digamos de de
buenas noticias lo que habíamos visto
hasta el domingo fue contra muchas
expectativas un traslado Pacífico del
poder de un polo a otro pero después se
complicó por unas partidarias unas
fanáticos que decidieron que no iban a
aceptar de ninguna manera el resultado
de la elección y eso muestra otro otro
sí voy a darle la palabra a Diego
Sánchez ancochea nuestro siguiente
invitado para conocer ese panorama
general y luego ya nos vamos metiendo en
los diferentes temas subtemas que
tenemos para el programa Diego
bienvenido adelante su perspectiva
general para el 2023 qué es lo que usted
analiza para nuestra región en América
Latina
Muchísimas gracias buenas tardes o
noches a los oyentes es un gusto estar
aquí compartir con ustedes Santiago y
con con Iván yo creo que para completar
lo que decía Iván es importante entender
que la región viene de otra nueva década
perdida como la de los 80 los últimos
años han sido de crecimiento en el pib
Per cápita y el año que viene va a ser
todavía peor que este año se espera que
la región crezca solo uno punto cuatro
por ciento y el sur de América la
1.2% y es en este panorama de bajo
crecimiento Y en este panorama de
descontento social ante esta situación
en la que cabe situar tanto los
desarrollos políticos como los
desarrollos económicos que que van a
tener lugar creo que va a ser un año en
el que varios de los gobiernos van a
querer hacer más para responder a esas
demandas sociales para tratar de
promover el crecimiento y Tendremos que
ver si se encuentran ante las
dificultades para lograrlo por
unos mercados nacionales e
internacionales que miran este tipo de
políticas con sospechas y que
promocionan la austeridad por tanto creo
que un panorama complicado complicado
por De dónde venimos complicado por
dónde estamos y complicado por una
relación muy compleja entre lo económico
y lo político relación compleja en
resumidas cuentas unos malos augurios y
una década perdida es básicamente lo que
puedo recoger de esta perspectiva va a
ser un año difícil en términos
económicos le doy la palabra ahora a
Iván para que entremos entonces a hablar
del tema de la estabilidad política ya
está usted mencionando lo que está
sucediendo en Perú vimos las imágenes de
lo que sucedió en Brasil Cuál va a ser
Entonces el reto para para nuestra
región
todos estos dos escenarios que tenemos
en países como Perú y Brasil que se
puede esperar para el 2023 teniendo este
malestar político esta inestabilidad y
también está polarización a nivel social
obviamente lo que lo que hemos visto
políticamente en el último año año y
media ha sido la victoria de una serie
de candidatos y fuerzas políticas
básicamente la izquierda en toda la
región que podría podría ser visto de
dos maneras fundamentalmente uno es
digamos parte de un hola de cambio en
toda la región después del período de
dominación por la derecha y el centro
derecha de 2015 a 2018 más o menos pero
en el medio vino la pandemia y la
pandemia agradó por supuesto la
desigualdad en la región
agravó las circunstancias económicas de
muchísimas personas sobre todos en la
economía informal y y y hizo que había
un reclamo general para un cambio
fundamental en la política Que
obviamente tuvo el bueno se manifestó en
las grandes protestas que vimos en 2019
en 2021 sobre todo en en Colombia ahora
ha ocurrido ese cambio en varios países
pero yo creo que lo que vamos a dar son
los diferentes rumbos que que ASUME
ahora tenemos el caso obviamente de Lula
que tienen un frente doméstico de
inestabilidad de desafío a su control
político muy fuerte y tenemos lo de
Petro en Colombia que es muy interesante
que Pedro Está avanzando en múltiples
diferencias líneas en la económica con
la reforma fiscal que que hace poco era
aprobado en la línea de la pacificación
del país por medio del diálogo con
múltiples diferentes grupos armados que
ya está en marcha con el intento de
reconstruir las relaciones con con
Venezuela Y entonces vemos como una
versión
moderada pragmático dialogante pero de
izquierda también buscando cambia el
modelo social y económico del país y yo
creo que lo que vamos a ver digamos son
intentos de lograr ese cambio en Chile
también que a veces no tienen el éxito
deseado a veces encuentro muchas
resistencia a veces las fuerzas
políticas que hemos visto en el caso de
Perú el caso de Pedro Castillo eran tan
débiles y no tenían experiencia ni
capacidad de manejar los asuntos del
país que eventualmente fracasaron pero
vamos a ver Ojalá algunos éxitos en este
sentido tal vez en el caso colombiano y
yo creo que va a ser interesante mirar
las diferentes las diferentes ejemplos y
vamos a ver probablemente por último
Argentina en lo que probablemente será
el último año del gobierno peronista y
una lección muy reñido que va a cubrir
en octubre y noviembre
que ahí está el foco principal para esas
tres erecciones también importantes en
Guatemala en Paraguay y en Argentina
dado el contexto que está viviendo cada
uno de esos países paso a preguntarle a
Diego por el caso particular de Brasil
en términos económicos porque llega el
gobierno de Lula 50% digámoslo así la
mitad de la población muy esperanzada
con este cambio que puede traer el en
términos económicos fue su gran carta a
la hora de presentar un programa de
gobierno para cautivar al electorado
Pero la realidad brasileña para este
2023 es muy distinta a la realidad
brasileña que tuvo Lula da Silva en sus
dos primeros gobiernos que podemos
hablar en materia económica para este
país las dificultades o retos que pueda
tener o si podemos estar ante un proceso
de recuperación de Brasil de la mano de
Lula que puede servir de digamos de un
efecto de bola de nieve para el resto de
la región
importantísima la pregunta Santiago en
un momento donde como hablábamos antes
lo económico es tan importante yo creo
que volviendo a lo que tú decías
comparando el primer Lula y el de ahora
es importante que antes de contestar nos
acordemos de que en América Latina las
condiciones externas determinan mucho de
lo que va a pasar en las economías
nacionales y fundamentalmente la
evolución del precio de las materias
primas y la evolución de los tipos de
interés y de los flujos de capitales son
los elementos fundamentales Entonces es
importante entender que parte de lo que
va a pasar en París en Brasil
tiene que ver con la recuperación China
tiene que ver con la Guerra de Ucrania
tiene que ver con elementos externos que
van a ser importantes para determinar la
demanda de exportaciones de Brasil dicho
lo cual yo creo que el gran reto de Lula
va a ser
conseguir focalizar el gasto público en
su agenda social en su agenda de
reducción de la desigualdad hacerlo de
forma rápida sin aumentar de forma
significativa el déficit público para
ello idealmente obviamente
recuperar la agenda de los impuestos
como decía Iván algo que ha sucedido en
Colombia sería importante pero ahí va a
ser enormemente difícil por la ausencia
de una mayoría progresista en el
congreso por tanto te diría que uno
tenemos que considerar lo externo dos
creo que va a haber un intento de
focalizar en lo social y tercero tenemos
que tener muy en cuenta avances o no la
política tributaria Iván Ya le voy a
preguntar a usted por el caso político
de Perú para que profundicemos en él
aprovecho que estoy con Diego hablando
del tema económico de Brasil mercosur en
importante hablar del tema Argentina un
país que va de Cara a unas elecciones
presidenciales con una economía con
muchísimos problemas una alta inflación
y sobre todo deuda que es incontrolable
para los gobiernos de turno allí en
Buenos Aires perspectiva para este país
que es pese a los a los problemas que
tiene sigue siendo una economía
importante para la región
sí creo que en Argentina es
importantísimo distinguir entre los
problemas estructurales y el momento
actual parte de lo que no hacemos bien
Muchas veces es
vincular lo coyuntural con lo
estructural el problema argentino viene
como bien sabemos desde los años 80 y de
las dificultades para resolver la crisis
de la deuda de los años 80 y nunca se ha
sabido resolver Y el 2023 me temo no va
a ser el año
van a ser unas elecciones muy
complicadas
con pocos líderes políticos
populares con muchas promesas difíciles
de cumplir y con la dificultad para
hacer el contexto creo que sinceramente
que lo único que podría salvar a
Argentina es una recuperación china más
rápida de lo esperado que permita el
aumento en el precio de la soja y de
otros materias primas y eso permita un
crecimiento de la economía Argentina y
lo contrario van a ser nuestras
lecciones muy ruidosas pero con poca
capacidad de afectar a lo económico poca
capacidad Iván regreso con usted
Hablemos del caso Perú un tema político
allí importante la salida del presidente
Castillo este gobierno interino que
genera muchísimas
diferentes puntos de vista allí en Perú
vemos las manifestaciones esto puede
generar también un efecto de bola de
nieve en otros países que están con este
mismo malestar político pongo un vecino
que no está muy lejos Bolivia en donde
también hay una tensión muy grande en el
departamento de Santa Cruz
obviamente lo que vimos con el el la
detención de Camacho antes del del año
nuevo no este es o sea Bolivia siempre
tiene la la la posibilidad de entrar de
nuevo en un nuevo conflicto debido a las
divisiones las clivajes que existen en
el país estamos hablando por supuesto
del clivaje étnico el clima giracional y
los clibajes que resultan de la alta
desigualdad que existe en ese país y
muchos otros países de América Latina el
gobierno de Arce ha sido
relativamente intransigente en el
tratamiento de lo que lo que ellos ven
como los golpistas responsable para la
destitución del Evo Morales en 2019
Aunque obviamente esos mismos opositores
al actual gobierno insisten que había
una fraude electoral y ellos están
protestando contra esa división que
viene de obviamente antes de 2019
sigue siendo digamos el factor
fundamental en la política boliviana es
muy difícil como en Bolivia como en Perú
ver cómo se hace digamos fuentes de
entendimiento como
convertir el sistema político en un
informe de dirigir estas diferencias Y
resolverlos en lugar de ser
fundamentalmente un plataforma para
ocasionales elecciones en que sirve a
los candidatos para ganar captar votos
para ganar interés y movilizar sus
partidarios a grabar las diferentes
porque lo que estamos viendo sobre todo
en las elecciones que pienso obviamente
Perú de 2021 Colombia del año pasado
segundas vueltas muy reñidos entre
candidatos que siempre de sus diferentes
lados izquierda y derecha apelaban al al
populismo como método de digamos atraer
los las más gran cantidad de votos
posibles en el caso de Pedro hemos visto
después una seriedad y una moderación en
gobierno que es es Es muy prometedor el
problema es en otros casos es unidad de
polarización
y populismo sigue y obviamente hay que
poner otro caso en sobre la mesa que es
el caso del sábado yo creo que todos los
políticos de América Latina Ahora ven a
nadie bukele como un posible ejemplo a
seguir por qué porque tiene 90 por
ciento de popularidad en el país y un
dominio de las instituciones estatales
absolutamente completo y el peligro es
que personas que lleguen a poder con
digamos el voto populista con la llamada
digamos
de para captar los los otros posibles
para luchar contra el estado corrupto y
que que existía supuestamente antes
miran a bukele como un ejemplo para
seguir y
atrincheras en el poder Iván yo le
propongo que dejemos el tema de los
liderazgos sobre la mesa para tratarlo
en unos minutos Deja ahí también
pendiente el tema de bukele Ya lo vamos
a profundizar
preguntarle a Diego por este caso de
Perú y Bolivia porque pese a estos
remesones políticos que están viviendo
estos dos países andinos Perú en
términos económicos le está yendo
bastante bien si uno lo compara con la
región y Bolivia Ha logrado digamos
capotear un poco el tema de la inflación
a pesar de de la situación que está
viviendo cómo hacen estos países por lo
menos el caso de Perú para que tenga un
desempeño económico mejor que sus
vecinos que son un poco más estables
Santiago antes de contestar me gustaría
poner sobre la mesa que parte de lo que
estamos hablando es la debilidad de la
Democracia pero una debilidad democracia
que se experimenta de forma muy distinta
en los distintos países quizás sea algo
que podamos discutir pero yendo yendo a
tu pregunta creo que aquí es muy
importante de todas maneras distinguir
lo que es rendimiento económico en
términos del pib per cápita y
rendimiento económico en términos del
desarrollo humano y de la capacidad de
asegurar una buena vida para la mayoría
de la población
el tema en Perú siempre ha sido que hay
un cierto consenso tanto en las élites
políticas tecnocráticas no no tanto el
presidente pero sí los
servidores públicos como en la élite
económica sobre el mantenimiento de un
modelo basado en estabilidad
macroeconómica y en el crecimiento del
sector minero Y esa es dos elementos se
ha mantenido a pesar de toda la
incertidumbre es políticas y la
inestabilidad política Pero y han
permitido el crecimiento pero no han
permitido
encontrar un desarrollo en mí a nivel
regional ni a nivel de buena parte de la
población y es esa descontento regional
por un modelo que es capaz de crecer
pero no de distribuir el que está sí
contribuyendo a los problemas
políticos entonces la pregunta la en
Perú es hasta qué punto o cuándo esa
inestabilidad política y social afectará
al crecimiento o no lo afectará el caso
boliviano es quizás más interesante
porque creo que ha sido en parte capaz
de redistribuir de forma que a pesar de
toda la debilidad política de la que nos
hablaba Iván ha sido capaz de tener un
crecimiento un crecimiento económico
relativamente alto pero a la vez con
mayor redistribución a nivel tanto
regional como social y eso lo ha hecho
más prometedor al menos en los últimos
años acordémonos que el coeficiente de
gini que mide la desigualdad ha caído en
Bolivia más que ningún otro país de la
región en los últimos 15 años
iban que podemos decir de tres gobiernos
muy particulares de nuestra región y es
el caso de Venezuela de Cuba y de
Nicaragua gobiernos muy criticados a
nivel internacional muy controvertidos
vemos un país como Venezuela tratando de
volverse a insertar en el escenario
internacional de volver a tener algo de
visibilidad pero también vemos a
Nicaragua y un Cuba que prácticamente
están tratando de pasar entre las
sombras para mantenerse en el poder y
seguir manteniendo el status quo que han
que han establecido en esos países Cuál
es su análisis
yo creo que son dos o tres países
bastante distintos obviamente ha
existido ha existido desde los tiempos
de John pauls en la administración de
Trump la idea de que son las Troy que de
tiranía pero los tres tienen
están en diferentes trayectos en este
momento lo que sí es un y lo común entre
los tres son los graves problemas
económicos que comparten Cuba tiene o ha
tenido un año dificilísimo la
infraestructura están muy mal estado hay
digamos A falta de disponibilidad de de
capacidad de consumo de las personas y y
lo que hemos escuchado de Cuba es es una
situación económica muy grave Venezuela
también obviamente ha tenido un enorme
caída en la Pipe en los últimos años y
Nicaragua un poco menos pero lo que veo
son digamos diferentes trayectorias
sobre todo en cuanto a la deriva o la
consolidación autoritario claramente
Nicaragua ahora está en un extremo la
detención de cientos de opositores de
los principales candidatos
presidenciales de hace un par de años la
represión el cierre de miles es absoluto
es casi imposible trabajar
independientemente ser periodista se
comentarista en Nicaragua hoy en día y
Nicaragua y el gobierno Parece que esta
se está poniendo de espaldas a los otros
gobiernos la región cuál que el gobierno
que se asoma y dicen Ortega Tal vez es
tiempo de digamos moderar su represión y
Busca una salida negociado con oposición
recibe el repudio más absoluto del
presidente Ortega y su esposa
vicepresidente y Rosario Murillo
Nicaragua es un caso yo diré a parte
extremadamente muy complicado que va a
ser un desafío muy grande es interesante
que Lula viene a poder porque el lunes
sí tiene conexiones históricos con
líderes como Ortega y otros no lo podría
de alguna manera Crea una cuenta pero
veo a Nicaragua en un extremo y
Venezuela un poco al otro lado porque
aunque sigue existiendo represión sigue
existiendo Pues de seguridad y policía
secreto muy fuerte maduro está
intentando
Buscar la legitimidad de nuevo
ciertos espacios regionales en 2021 la
vuelta a las negociaciones con la
oposición recientemente en la Ciudad de
México yo creo que hay un pequeño
apertura en Venezuela lo que no hay en
Nicaragua para nada Ustedes mencionaban
dos puntos muy importantes que quiero
que analicemos a partir de este momento
y es los liderazgos en la región y
también el estado de la Democracia
muchos países dieron virajes con
dificultades o procesos democráticos
con ciertas críticas o no pero hubo
virajes en términos políticos y también
eso consolidó una tendencia política que
tiene que afianzarse lo decía yo en la
introducción del programa a lo largo de
este 2023 Cómo ven ustedes los
liderazgos Cómo ven ustedes esa
izquierda que ahora tiene mayoría por lo
menos en Suramérica que pueda
consolidarse o no ese proyecto también
teniendo en cuenta que hay países que
van a elecciones y pueden tener unos
virajes radicales veamos cuál es la
opinión entonces de Diego el tema de la
Democracia el estado democrático y los
liderazgos para mí mencionabas la
izquierda también es es importantísimo
distinguir entre los clibajes sobre la
democracia el cribaje económico así
tenemos que países por ejemplo como
chile han mirado a la izquierda pero
tienen una democracia sin duda vibrante
de este a pesar de los problemas o el
mismo caso de Perú Es complicado porque
aunque hablamos de debilidad democrática
el hecho es que o el intento de
autogolpe fracasó y el hecho es que es
de utilizar los procedimientos
institucionales para asegurar la
continuidad entonces me parece que hay
que distinguir entre izquierda y derecha
en lo económico y también hay que entre
compromiso por la democracia y no
compromiso por la democracia y ahí Creo
que el comentario que hacía Iván de la
importancia o el coste que está teniendo
en los nuevos liderazgos en
Centroamérica es particularmente
importante él hablaba de bukele y quizás
quiera desarrollar la idea que creo que
ha sido un líder realmente peligroso
para la región pero que tiene que ver
también con las discontinuidades
democráticas y las dificultades en
Guatemala que tiene también que ver con
lo que nos decía Iván está pasando en
Nicaragua por tanto para mí más que
hablar de derecha y creo que es
importante hablar de
procesos de redistribución democrática y
procesos de involución democrática nunca
al medio y largo plazo son capaces de
generar suficiente cambio económico y de
alternancia le añadiría yo porque para
Colombia fue muy representativo esta
alternancia de política que está
viviendo ese país suramericano en Iván
su opinión liderazgos y también estado
de la Democracia adelante Bueno yo o sea
obviamente hay muchas diferentes figuras
de hecho se parece hoy en día que hay
una competencia de belleza entre
diferentes
presidentes que quieren liderar la
izquierda en América Latina entre por
Petro Maduro que tiene como digamos
anhelos En esa dirección y Lula por
supuesto y amlo amlo en México pero o
sea en términos generales o sea estoy de
acuerdo plenamente con lo que lo que
dice Diego y yo creo que a veces la
diferencia entre izquierda y derecha no
no ayuda muchísimo a violaciones de
derechos humanos y y de nombres
democráticos por gobiernos de los de los
dos bandas digamos Pero yo creo que sí
la izquierda la nueva izquierda con la
que vemos hoy en día tiene está mucho
más empeñado empeñado en en resolver el
tema histórico de la desigualdad
está muy consciente de la importancia de
la percepción de la desigualdad que vino
la pandemia donde realmente el tema de
vida o muerte
la clase de donde venía el tipo de
trabajo que tenía y el sueldo que
ostentaba en ese momento y yo creo que
esa tacto ha sido notorio y en la
elección de castillo en Perú que vino de
la absoluta nada pero que representaba
un un rechazo casi completo del sistema
y una
revalorización de la de la comunidad
sobre todo en el país Yo creo que el
problema lo que veo en diferentes
contextos de América Latina es que los
problemas la política
produce nuevos liderazgos produce
esperanza en en en en en Colombia o en
Perú o en Brasil la emoción colectiva
que ha generado estas victorias
políticas a lo largo de los últimos
meses y años ha sido enorme pero
trasladar es energía de colectiva
emocional política al cambio estructural
del estado y en las sociedades es
sumamente difícil porque solamente para
dar un ejemplo porque en Colombia
todavía después de décadas hablamos de
la falta de presencia del estado en los
territorios porque cuando miramos las
cifras de los organismos económicas los
estados no pueden por sus gastos cambiar
el de la desigualdad porque es una
economía informal países a pesar de
todos los esfuerzos del Estado estamos
viendo de nuevo sus problemas
estructurales Y por qué los servicios
publicados públicos son tan malos que
fue el gran
lastre de la primera ola izquierda la
marea roja Por qué Y estos son los temas
que espero que los nuevos líderes van a
tratar que empiezan a repetirse en
diferentes países ya entramos en el
último bloque del programa quiero que
hablemos de la integración de la región
la integración latinoamericana deuda
pendiente a lo largo de los últimos años
le doy la palabra a Diego porque nos
cuesta tanto y tal vez el 2023 puede ser
un año en el que demos un paso para
mejorar la integración de la región
teniendo bloques como por ejemplo un
mercosur dividido con fracturas y una
alianza del Pacífico que está pues como
en un limbo por lo menos para el 2022
Santiago no te pido disculpas pero antes
de decir eso solo añadiría todo lo
anterior que los impuestos son
fundamentales para mí la agenda
impositiva va a ser una de las que
distingas y la región Avanza o no y por
eso por mucho que se pueda discutir
sobre algunos de los defectos del
gobierno de Petro creo que el gran éxito
como decía Iván de la reforma impositiva
y una reforma progresista progresiva ha
sido importante que tenemos que ver sin
otros países tiene lugar pero yendo a tu
pregunta yo no soy particularmente
optimistas sobre el avance del
regionalismo porque
el gran optimismo vendría de Brasil
vendría de la elección de Lula y vendría
de la capacidad de Lula de proyectar un
Brasil distinto sin duda al que lo hacía
bolsonaro el problema es que como
hablábamos antes Brasil tiene tantos
problemas internos en este momento y
tanta dificultad para conseguir un
bloque
dominante en el congreso que va a
difícil que impulse la agenda pero creo
que ahí hay un elemento positivo a tener
en cuenta la otra integración que no es
la que tú tenías en mente Pero creo que
es importante y no hemos conversado
mucho sobre México es los El Avance que
es posible que haya en la integración
dentro del norte de América más que del
sur de América porque como bien sabemos
las empresas estadounidenses están
buscando formas de compensar o de
reducir su dependencia de China y eso
está llevando a un proceso de insuran y
un proceso de regionalización que puede
beneficiar a México Entonces si dijera
creo que el regionalismo al final está
determinado en parte por fuerzas
económicas que esas van a ser más
importantes en el norte que en el sur de
la región Iván su opinión sobre el tema
de la integración
absolutamente hay que reconocer De
antemano estoy de acuerdo totalmente que
lo que he dicho ciego pero
las instituciones regionales han tenido
unos años de colapso y de absolutamente
estrepitoso o sea vemos la humanización
de Estados Americanos que está o sea ha
perdido totalmente la confianza por
parte de los gobiernos de izquierda la
región después de la suposición sobre
Venezuela y su participación en las
elecciones de Bolivia en 2019 el celac
es de interés para la Unión Europea
sobre todo y de China como un Oriente
locución pero es débil operado por
consenso no tiene institución atrás un
azor casi no existe más hay un trabajo
muy grande que hay que hacer en términos
de integración regional y obviamente
Tenemos muchos países donde los líderes
los nuevos gobiernos están mirando su
propio patio su propios asuntos internos
y el caso de Brasil es el llamativo en
ese punto realmente hay mucho esperanza
en el gobierno de la política exterior
los primeros gobiernos de de Lula fue
muy prominente tuvo un papel platónico
en en la integración regional en ese
momento participó plenamente Brasil en
la misión de de paz en en Haití por
supuesto claro abrió una serie de
embajadas en África o sea eso es la
esperanza pero yo creo que no puede ser
todo la responsabilidad de lo que se
necesita claro
tratar la disputa más grave y la crisis
humanitaria más importante en la región
con una respuesta consolidada y eso es
en relación a Venezuela es muy
importante que los países la región
intenta una conversación asistente con
maduro acerca de Venezuela y las
elecciones del año que viene rápidamente
me queda un minuto para finalizar el
programa Diego su conclusión para el
2023 de América Latina rápidamente
Exacto sí rápidamente Yo diría que ante
un contexto económico internacional
enormemente difícil lo que se juega en
la región es los gobiernos apuestan por
la austeridad o son capaces de aumentar
impuestos y con eso gasto social por un
lado por el otro Qué países son capaces
de fortalecer la democracia versus Qué
países va a haber un debilitamiento o
bien por el tipo de Liderazgo que hemos
discutido por otros motivos iban
rápidamente para el cierre su conclusión
si vas a una un conflicto en todos los
países entre la fe en el futuro y las
restricciones y dificultades del
presente y mente los gobiernos pueden
convencer sus electorados que la cosa va
a mejorar una vez que la condición es
económicas mejoren más próximos años yo
creo que van a sobrevivir y van a
prosperar Pues si van y Diego les
agradezco mucho por este análisis para
la audiencia de France 24 año difícil
para la región de América Latina muchos
retos por delante ya veremos Entonces
cómo se desarrollan estos próximos 12 es
todo por hoy En nombre del equipo
técnico Les agradecemos la sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Keyla maestra y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera
Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros siga con France 24
[Música]